Welcome to another Unreal Engine training course.
Today we're going to be looking at an introduction to Control Rig.
So we'll take a look at how rigging works in Unreal,
and what the concept of a Control Rig is and so how they work.
And then we'll create our own Control Rig,
going over how to create controls and set their transforms,
and then set up the logic to make them drive your skeleton with a simple FK setup,
and then get a little more complex with a simple IK setup.
And then we'll see how to set up an aim control.
So there are a lot of different benefits for this,
which allow you to easily control what something is pointing at,
like somebody's head or a turret of a gun, for example.
And lastly, we'll take our Control Rig into Sequencer
and see how you can animate with it directly in the engine.
So let's start off with what Control Rig is and what it can do.
So Control Rig is a sort of umbrella term for a suite of tools
that you can use to rig and animate your characters in engine.
There's a lot of familiar functionality with the way that Control Rigs are set up
and how they function when you compare it to external rigging softwares.
And it's super user-friendly with visual scripting,
like you'd use in a traditional blueprint,
with nodes and functions to easily connect your controls to your bones for animating.
And it has some great functionality, like procedural rigging or modular rigging,
where you can create controls and hierarchies automatically,
based on various tags and metadata that you can set up,
or even create template rigs that work across several different characters in your project.
And the best part is you don't need to know how to write any code to set up advanced rigs,
but you can use the Python editor to write tools or code directly in the engine,
and that'll help automate some of your workflow.
Now, if we jump inside the engine here,
this is the Control Rig Editor with an example of a Control Rig that's been created for our mannequin character.
And to give you an overview of the editor here,
in the center we have the Rig Graph,
which is similar to all of Unreal Engine's editors,
where you'd set up your visual scripting and all of your logic that would connect your controls and your bones together.
On the right-hand side we have the Details panel,
and this contains all of the information about the element that you currently have selected.
So if I was to select a control from the viewport here,
we can see what type of control it is, and some of the transform values on that control.
Coming down to the bottom left-hand side, we have a few different Rig menus.
So this first one is the Rig Hierarchy,
and this shows us the hierarchy of our Rig that's been created,
as well as the hierarchy of the skeleton that the Rig is connected to.
The next is the Execution Stack,
and this will give you a preview of the order of operation for the Control Rig logic.
Now this can really help with debugging your logic and seeing the sequence of events that are triggering.
And next we have the My Blueprint tab,
and this is similar to the panel you'll find in a regular blueprint,
where you can see your various functions and variables that you've created.
Now the slight difference is that the variables in here are meant to be used within your Rig Graph
as a way to drive logic, rather than being exposed when you have the asset in a level.
And if I zoom out of the Rig Graph here, you can see that the logic is split up into a few different branches.
And that's because there are a few different types of solve directions.
So control rigs are evaluated in several ways called solve directions,
and these allow you to split the logic into different streams or solvers,
which enable workflows such as rig sharing or baking your animation from your bones to your controls,
and even debugging the behavior inside your Rig logic.
So there are three solve directions we can look at.
Up the top here we have Forward Solve.
Now this is the primary solve direction for the control rig,
where you would set up the traditional rigging logic of having your controls drive your bones,
and then allow you to key the controls and animate your characters.
So next would be Backward Solve.
Now this is the inverse of Forward Solve, where you would have the bones drive the controls,
and this is intended to be used to bake skeletal animation back to the control rigging sequencer,
so that you could then easily make edits to the animation if you wanted to.
And the last we'll look at is Construction Event.
Now the Construction Event executes at the top of the stack,
and this is used to execute preparation logic,
so you could use it to initialize data like variables or spawn controls and set their initial positions,
so you can use those within the other two solve directions.
Now that we've gone over some of the basics of what control rig is, let's create our own.
So we'll create a new control rig, and we'll learn a couple of different methods of how to create new controls,
depending on the circumstances,
and then set up the logic to connect those directly to the bones,
giving us control over the character with a simple FK setup.
So inside the engine here, what we're going to do is create a new control rig for our Quinn character.
So to do that, we can do that one of two different ways.
We could right click, come up to Create, and choose Control Rig,
and what this will do is give us a control rig that's paired to the Quinn character skeletal mesh.
Now the second way that you could create a control rig is by right clicking in an empty space in the content browser,
coming up to Animation, and then down to Control Rig, and you could create a new control rig here.
This will give you another option, whether or not you want a standard control rig or a modular control rig,
that you could reuse with different characters.
But if we just choose Control Rig here to create a standard one, it will ask you to name it,
so I'll just rename it CRDemo for now.
Now the differences between these two is that our CRDemo control rig we just made
isn't paired or connected to any other character,
and what we'd have to do is come inside here, set our preview mesh, and import our hierarchy for that to be connected.
Something that you might have noticed when we right clicked in the content browser and came down to the Control Rig options
is the Control Shape Library.
Now this contains all of the Control Shape assets, where there are many different shapes available by default,
but you could use this to import and build your own library of shapes if you need something more custom or visually different for your rig.
We're going to look at two different methods we can use to create a new control.
With this first method, we'll create a control that doesn't have a relationship to any bones in the skeleton,
and then see how to reposition it and customize the look of it.
So if we come to our Rig hierarchy window here and scroll down to the bottom until we find an empty space,
I'll right click, come up to New, and select New Control.
Now what this will do is create a new control outside of the skeleton hierarchy,
and it'll position it at World Zero.
Now typically with new controls, especially with an FK setup,
you want their initial position to be in the location of the bone that you're trying to control.
So we could come into the window here, the Preview window, and reposition this up to the elbow, for example.
And we can actually get our control close to this bone and use a tool to snap it to its location.
So if we come to Character and just show bones so we can see the elbow joint here,
and we'll right click the control inside the Rig hierarchy window,
we have an option to set offset transform from closest bone.
And what this will do is snap its position and its orientation to the closest bone in the viewport.
And we can see that that's now positioned and oriented to the elbow joint.
So when we set up the logic, we know that they both have the same initial start points.
Now we can customize the look of these controls.
So if you select the control in the viewport or in the Rig hierarchy and come to the Details panel here,
under Shape we have Shape Properties.
Now this might be closed by default, but if we just pop it open.
And under the Shape dropdown, we have the default shape mesh here.
And so there are lots of different shapes here and you can just choose whatever's appropriate.
Now if we go for something like a circle thick here,
we can see that it's still slightly inside the mesh,
so what we could do is reposition the rotation of the shape.
And if we reposition it along a Y axis like this,
I think that's going to give us a result that we want to encompass the elbow.
So I'll just put 90 degrees inside the shape transforms.
And I'll actually scale it up just to make it a little bigger.
And now this is much easier to select and it's not stuck inside our mesh.
We can also change the color of the shape here.
And as you can see as we scrub through the various colors, it updates live in the viewport,
and you can also see the icon for the control down here changes color to match.
So I'm just going to make it green for now.
And that's it, we've made our first control.